>> LEFT WING AGITATORS PROMISING
A NIGHT OF RAGE FOR THE SUPREME
COURT AS BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
TURN A BLIND EYE.
BARRICADES ARE GOING UP AROUND
THE BUILDING WITH THE JUSTICES
POISED TO ISSUE THEIR RULING ON
ABORTION EITHER THIS WEEK OR
NEXT.
THE GROUP JANE'S REVENGE,
ISSUING A CALL TO RIOT AGAINST
THE TOP COURT IF ROE GOES.
SO FAR MORE THAN 40 ATTACKS ON
PRO-LIFE GROUPS IN CHUMPS AND
PROTESTING CONTINUES OUTSIDE THE
HOMES OF THE JUSTICES.
REPUBLICAN SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY
BLASTING THE LEFT OVER THE
TACTICS.
>> THIS IS DRIVEN BY THE WOKE
LEFT.
WHEN THE DRAFT OPINION WAS
LEAKED, THE WOKER'S RESPONSE WAS
IMMEDIATE.
THEY SAID, "WE DON'T AGREE WITH
IT, SO LET'S BURN THE PLACE
DOWN.
LET'S INTIMIDATE THE JUSTICES.
LET'S INTIMIDATE THEIR SPOUSES.
LET'S INTIMIDATE THEIR KIDS.
WHAT YOU ALLOW IS WHAT WILL
CONTINUE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
EMBRACED THAT.
>> YOU COULD SAY IT'S HYPERBOLE
EMBRACING, BUT DEFINITELY BY
THEIR SILENCE HAVE GIVEN A
COMPLICIT CONSENT.
WHAT'S NEXT?
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES MOVE OUT OF THEIR
HOMES AND LIVE IN A COMPOUND?
>> MAYBE LIVE IN EUROPE AND RULE
FROM THERE.
IT'S ABSURD THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS TIME TO GO ALL THE
WAY TO KYIV TO TALK ABOUT -- HE
WAS THERE TODAY -- TO TALK ABOUT
HELPING THEM, ENSURE THERE'S
JUSTICE, BUT NEITHER HE, NOR
BIDEN, CAN MENTION ANYTHING
HAPPENING 10 MINUTES AWAY FROM
THEIR OFFICES.
>> YEAH.
>> THERE'S BEEN NO DETERRENT,
RIGHT?
THESE PROTESTS, AT THE JUSTICES'
HOMES, THEY ARE ILLEGAL.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO ARREST ONE, HAVE A LITTLE
DETERRENCE, SHOW THERE'S GOING
TO BE PUSHBACK.
THEY'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING.
WHAT HAPPENS?
ALL THESE PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO IT.
THOSE YOUNG WOMEN PROTESTING
THERE, WITH THE BLOOD ON THEIR
PANTS, THE BABY DOLLS, THEY'RE
BEING PAID.
THAT'S THEIR SUMMER JOB.
>> RIGHT.
>> THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE ALL SUMMER LONG.
>> JUDGE, THIS IS PETTY, BUT
I'LL SAY WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE
GOOSE, GOOD FOR THE GANDER.
WHY NOT HAVE THE PERSONAL INFO
OF THE ILLEGAL PROTESTERS
PUBLIC, PUT OUT THEIR ADDRESSES?
>> WELL, THIS IS JUST -- THIS IS
A MICROCOSM OF WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE COUNTRY AT LARGE.
YOU'VE GOT THE REPUBLICANS WHO
FOR THE MOST PART, YOU KNOW, AND
JANUARY 6th IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT, AND WE ALL AGREE THAT
WHOEVER VIOLATED THE LAW SHOULD
BE PROSECUTED, BUT WHAT YOU'VE
GOT HERE, YOU'VE GOT THE
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE NOT DOING,
WHEN THEY'RE IN OFFICE, TO THE
DEMOCRATS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS DO
TO THE REPUBLICANS.
AND IT'S, LIKE, UMM, IN THIS
GAZE, YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE YELLING,
WE'RE GOING TO -- IF THIS
DECISION COMES DOWN THAT SAYS
THAT ABORTION IS NOT A FEDERAL
RIGHT, THEN WE'RE GOING TO BURN
THE CITY DOWN.
WE'RE GOING TO TEAR EVERYTHING
DOWN.
WE'RE GOING TO UNLEASH THE FURY.
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO ITS WE'RE
GOING TO HIT THE STREETS.
WE SAID WE'D RIOT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO.
THAT'S WHAT THE LEFT DOES.
SO IN THE SUMMER OF 2020, WE HAD
BLACK LIVES MATTER BURNING DOWN
THE STREETS AND MEDIA SAY DON'T
BELIEVE YOUR LYING EYES.
SUMMER OF 2022, IF THIS THING
SPINS OFF THE WAY THEY WANT IT
THE SAME THING WILL HAPPEN.
ALL A PROSECUTOR NEEDS TO DO ITS
ENFORCE THE LAW.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF THE JUSTICES' HOUSES
UNTIL THERE'S A DECISION IS
VIOLATING THE LAW.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
AS A PROSECUTOR, WHAT YOU DO YOU
GO IN AND INFILTRATE.
YOU SEND SOMEONE IN TO JANE'S
REVENGE AND YOU FIND OUT WHAT IS
THEIR MO, WHO IS THEIR LEADER,
THIS IS AN ORGANIZED CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE.
NOBODY IS PUTTING UP THOSE
FLYERS FOR FREE.
>> TALK ABOUT A MISERABLE
UNDERCOVER JOB.
IT MIGHT BE MORE FUN TO DO A
DRUG CARTEL OR THE MAFIA.
YOU KNOW, I'M GOING UNDERCOVER
FOR JANE'S REVENGE.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS NO ONE IS
STOPPING THEM.
SO THE RIGHT IS SAYING, GO
AHEAD, STEP ON US, BURN OUR
CITIES, OUR BUSINESSES, OUR
PRECINCTS, GO INTO OUR CHURCHES,
I'M ROMAN CATHOLIC, BURN THE
TABERNACLE.
THEY'RE OKAY.
>> I DON'T THINK WE'RE ALL OKAY.
>> PEOPLE IN POWER ARE OKAY.
>> WHAT IF JESSE AND I WENT ROAD
TRIPPING, WENT OUTSIDE THE
HOUSE, SET UP A COOLER OF BEER.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN, HAROLD?
>> LOOK, I'M NOT AN ADVOCATE OF
VIOLENCE.
>> NOTHING VIOLENT ABOUT BEER.
>> IF YOU WANT TO DO THAT, I
THINK YOU SHOULD DO IT.
I MIGHT JOIN YOU.
THERE WILL BE ELECTORAL
CONSEQUENCES IF THE COURT -- IF
WHAT WE BELIEVE THE COURT IS
GOING TO DO TO ROE.
THIS IS A 50-YEAR PRECEDENT.
I'M 52-YEAR-OLDS.
WE'VE NOT SEEN A CASE LIKE THIS
IN MY LIFETIME THAT WILL STIR
THE NATION, THAT HAS POTENTIAL
TO STIR THE NATION LIKE THIS
ONE.
THIS IS NOT AT ALL A
JUSTIFICATION, YOUR HONOR, FOR
ANY KIND OF VIOLENT ACT.
I WOULD AGREE, YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AN HOW TO DEAL
AROUND THIS, INFILTRATING
GROUPS, IS SMART TO DO.
I WAS SPEAKING WITH A REPUBLICAN
THE OTHER NIGHT WHO WAS FRANKLY
UNAWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON
AROUND ROE, AND WAS SURPRISED.
SHE'S A REPUBLICAN WOMAN.
SHE SAID, LOOK, IF THIS IS
OVERTURNED, THIS IS GOING TO
MAKE ME RETHINK A LOT OF THINGS.
HAVING SAID THAT, THERE'S NO
EXCUSE.
I HOPE ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND,
THE PRESIDENT, AND OTHERS, IF
THIS DECISION COMES DOWN LIKE WE
THINK IT WILL COME DOWN, WILL
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO PROTEST
PEACEFULLY, ENCOURAGE
PROSECUTORS TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
THIS IS NOT A DEMOCRATIC
PROBLEM.
SOME GUY IN MISSOURI, SAYING
HE'S REPUBLICAN, RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
I SAW DAN CRENSHAW GET PUSHED UP
AGAINST THE WALL AT A REPUBLICAN
EVENT, AND HIS STAFF, BECAUSE WE
HAVE A SENSE IN OUR COUNTRY, IF
YOU DON'T AGREE WITH ME, NOT
ONLY WILL I CANCEL YOU, I'M
GOING TO PHYSICALLY BEAT YOU,
IMPOSE VIOLENCE ON YOU.
POLITICS IS FOUGHT AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
IT'S NOT FOUGHT WITH VIOLENCE ON
YOUR POLITICAL OPPONENT.
A GREAT PIECE IN THE WASHINGTON
STREET JOURNAL WITH SOTOMAYOR
SPEAKING ABOUT CLARENCE THOMAS,
SAYING THEY DISAGREE ON THINGS,
BUT I LIKE HIM, HE'S A FRIEND OF
MINE, AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT
MOTIVATES ME.
I WISH EVERYONE WOULD READ THAT
AND TRY TO APPLY THAT TO PEOPLE
WHO YOU MAY DISAGREE WITH.
>> HAROLD, I RAN THAT ENTIRE
MONOLOGUE LAST NIGHT.
>> DID YOU?
>> AT LEAST I KNOW SOME PEOPLE
DON'T WATCH MY SHOW.
I'LL TRY TO LET THAT SLIDE, BUT
IT HURTS ME, HAROLD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, JESSE?
>> I THINK THAT LANDSCAPING AT
THAT PROPERTY IS PHENOMENAL.
AS SOMEONE WHO MOWED LAWNS MY
WHOLE LIFE, THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THIS DECISION IS BECAUSE CROOKED
LOST TO TRUMP.
THESE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE HER
THREE SUPREME COURT NOMINATIONS.
TRUMP GOT THEM INSTEAD.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THIS OPINION.
I THINK IT WAS SOMEONE THAT SAI,
GREG -- ELECTIONS HAVE
CANADIENS.
HAVE YOU HEARD THAT ONE BEFORE?
>> YEAH.
>> BACK IN THE DAY, YOU HAD A
PRESIDENT WHO GOT ELECTED, THEY
MIGHT SEND YOU TO THE JUNGLE TO
SHOOT AT THE VIETNAMESE.
IF SOMETHING COMES DOWN FROM
THIS COURT, IF YOU PRACTICE
UNSAFE SEX, YOU MAY HAVE TO
DRIVE OVER STATE LINES AND GET
AN ABORTION.
IT'S OVERBLOWN A LITTLE BIT.
AS THIS CASE IS ABOUT TO BE
DECIDED, GET AHEAD OF THIS.
YOU NEED TO SLEEP FEMALE FEDERAL
AGENTS INTO THIS JANE'S
ADDICTION -- JANE'S REVENGE, AND
PINCH THESE GUYS BEFORE THEY CAN
DO ANYTHING.
I THINK THE FBI HAS A LITTLE
HANGOVER FROM THE '60 AND
'70s.
THEY'RE AFRAID TO INFILTRATE THE
LEFT WING GROUPS, BECAUSE ALL
THEY DO IS RIGHT WING
INFILTRATION, AND WE KNOW THAT.
I WOULD BE ABLE TO DO IT MYSELF.
I'D THROWN ON A WIG.
WE HAVE HAIR AND MAKEUP.
PEOPLE HERE.
I WORE WIRES ON "THE FACTOR."
YOU GET IN, WEAR WIRES, AND BUST
THESE PEOPLE UP.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY SOMETHING
VERY SELFISH.
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW WITH OUR
SHOWS, THAT THE DAYS OF RAGE,
WILL CREATE A LOT OF TAPE.
PEOPLE SCREAMING AND YELLING.
I MEAN, WE NEED SOME OF THAT.
>> GREG, I SEE THE HUMAN ANGLE.
I DON'T SEE IT AS A TV PRODUCER.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M ASHAMED OF MYSELF.
>> YOU SHOULD BE.
>> I'M VERY ASHAMED OF MYSELF NO
WHAT I JUST SAID.
>> CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
>> NO.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK YOU ANYWAY.
YOU JUST SAID GARLAND IS IN
UKRAINE.
I KNOW HE'S IN UKRAINE.
BIDEN'S WIFE IS IN UKRAINE.
WHY ARE THEY ALL DOING IN
UKRAINE?
>> IT'S LIKE